[Music]
just reveal Selena Gomez's kidney
transplant complication that could have
turned fatal a few hours after our
surgery I woke up and had a text from
her that said I'm really scared with
that message from Selena the singers
best friend and kidney donor francia
raisa realized their 3-hour transplant
surgery didn't go as planned Francia
tells w magazine my kidney was very
active and i broke an artery they had to
take Selena into emergency surgery to
build a new artery to keep the kidney in
place she could have died the doctors
said that 50% of my recovery will be
mentality I wanted to get through it in
a way where I felt empowered two weeks
after their summer surgery Francia was
already auditioning for blackish
spin-off grown ish despite being in so
much pain she couldn't even open a door
and by November she was gushing about
her inspirational BFF having this news
drop was really hard for me because I've
never had anything personal out and she
just was like hey you know what I've
been yeah you're gonna be fine it's all
good meanwhile fans of Selena's old
friend Demi Lovato are asking did Nicki
Minaj nearly drive Demi to dream and the
new issue of Billboard magazine
recovering alcoholic Demi describes her
terrible experience at the 2016 Met Gala
does one celebrity was miserable to be
around I remember being so uncomfortable
that I wanted to drink she doesn't
mention any names but when Demi and
Nicki walked the red carpet together
with designer Jeremy Scott Nicki seemed
to be flashing Demi some side eye and
photos and freezing her out of there et
interview some say those painfully
awkward moments could have been what
made Demi leave the gala early for a
10:00 p.m. Alcoholics Anonymous meeting
she tells Billboard I still had millions
of dollars of diamonds on in an AAA
meeting and I related more to the
homeless people in that meeting than the
people at the Met Gala Thanks
you